suban las manos bendiciones gritan estos
seguidores del partido cristiano
nicaragüense para ellos solo dios podría
hacer ganar la presidencia a su
candidato guillermo osorno el pastor
evangélico de esta iglesia osorno es uno
de los cinco candidatos de derecha a
quienes las autoridades permitieron
realizar campaña contra el presidente
daniel ortega
todos los partidos opositores a los que
se les permitió correr en la contienda
electoral son desconocidos y tienen poca
o ninguna posibilidad de ganar porque no
podemos hacer caravana de vehículo en
campaña ni - de grupos ni menos de
pararse en una esquina con la foto de
los candidatos a presentarlo aunque la
campaña presidencial comenzó el sábado
las elecciones han perdido credibilidad
según el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken
ortega de 75 años busca su cuarto
mandato consecutivo junto a su esposa
como vicepresidente en mayo de este año
el gobierno del ex guerrillero
sandinista arrestó a los principales
candidatos de la oposición incluida su
principal rival cristiana chamorro
la policía también endureció sus medidas
contra la libertad de prensa pero ir a
votar envía un mensaje poderoso asegura
walter espinoza un candidato desconocido
a quien se le permitió postularse y está
consciente que si aquí no votamos
masivamente el 7 de noviembre aquí se
van a prestar al juego del continuismo
tras la violenta represión a las
protestas antigubernamentales de 2018
eeuu y la unión europea han impuesto
sanciones a funcionarios del gobierno el
mes pasado hicieron un llamado al
retorno de la democracia en nicaragua